Misao Lokove filozofije
ukratko izraženo, sastoji se u ovome.
Da se opšta predstava,
da se ono što je istinito,
to je da se saznanje zasniva na iskustvu.
Propisuje se kao put
saznanja s jedne strane iskustvo i
posmatranje, a s druge strane analiziranje
i isticanje opštih odredova.
To je empirizam koji metafizicira.
I to predstavlja uobičajeni put u naukama.
Ovim Hegelovim rečima
o Lokovoj filozofiji,
koju je napisao u svojoj istoriji
filozofije, započinjemo današnju emisiju.
Poštovani slušalci,
u današnjoj emisiji razgovaramo
sa Mašanom Bogdanovskim,
docentom na Filozofskom
fakultetu u Beogradu.
Dobrodošli na gozbu.
Hvala. Hvala.
Razgovaramo o filozofiji Johna Lockea,
o njegovoj epistemologiji,
ali i o epistemologiji religije.
Kako biste odredili taj značaj?